now I take slight issue with the wording
of part one I think it could be worded
better but it didn't stop you from
solving the question part 1 said show
and explain why f of X has an inverse
function it kind of left off something
something important which is that um you
know all functions for instance you know
like y equals x squared it has an
inverse function if you restrict it
right namely for positive values of x
okay so what we mean is what they're
Arthur is it has an inverse function for
all values of x okay so how do you
actually i'll leave my quick explain how
do you know whether something has an
inverse function or not why is it that i
have to restrict this in order to get an
inverse out of it it's a simple function
what's the problem with x squared Y
doesn't weigh close x squared Y doesn't
have an inverse function for all real
values of x hmm be careful so W a
language that you use right probably the
simplest way is to fit work a if I did
what we talked about before to get the
inverse function you switch variables
right yeah ah but this is not a function
this is not a function okay you get this
guy which is a relation okay now like
that corresponds to the reason why he
had not with the relation is because of
this point here you see why that's
abundant you remember us going over this
before what's significant about that
point it's a turning point not just a
stationary point it's turning point okay
so where you have something that turns
around that's what means values double
up okay so what I want to show is that
this thing never turns around okay now
that's kind of the informal language for
it I'm formally speaking what you want
is you want to show that it's
monotonically increasing or decreasing
okay it's always going up or it's always
going down in other words never turns
okay it never
so how are you going to go about showing
that how do I show that it's never going
to turn around well I need the
derivative don't I ok so I'm going to go
to F dash ok now probably to be easier
to notice that your original function is
really EV x minus neither Lotus X you
can see that just by index laws ok you
divide through so that's really super
easy to differentiate right what do you
get in the X and the double negative
cancels ok there you go ok so there's a
couple of different things you could say
at this point probably the easiest thing
is to say well e to the X right that
guy's positive if you wanted to protect
me about it you can take for all real
values of x ok there's nothing you can
put in there that will make that
negative nothing real anyway um you
could say the same for e to the minus X
right that's also positive for all real
values of x ok so you have two things
and they're always positive some of them
will also be positive ok so you can say
this and that of course is f dash ok so
what does this mean not only does it
never turn around its never even
stationary it's always going to be
positive in this case always going up
wouldn't matter if it was always going
down but we need to have it always going
somewhere we can't let it turn around
otherwise you get into this problem ok
so you can say therefore you could
either say there are no Tony points so
it has an inverse function for all the
others or alternatively you could say
it's monotonically increasing therefore
it has an inverse function for all real
values of x ok so they're looking for
this what was this worth was it one or
two to write ok so i would probably say
your first mark is in the
differentiation ok and then your second
mark is well what did you do with that
derivative like what was significant
about it that gets you to a result so
this is why it has an inverse ok that
was part one
okay what happened in part two okay now
I'll admit this was tricky but it was
definitely not impossible it's supriya
for a last question type question okay
remember I said before there are two
things you have to do to get from a
function to its inverse what were the
two things number one you have to swap
right and then number two you have to
change the subject right there you go
okay so um there's my is my function up
there okay you really can do it either
way the mats ends up being much the same
i'm going to do it in this one i'm going
to swap them then change the subject so
here's what I've got um let's just for
the sake of simplicity rather than ff-
and all I kind of think I'm just going
to call it this and call it why it's
just a little easier to work with with
the letters okay now if that's the
original then I'll swap them to get in
this and then all i need to do is tidy
up okay so here's my swap there you go
that's the inverse all i need to do is
rearrange this and make why the subject
okay now rightly you look at this and
you think Oh what do I do with this what
possible options do I have okay now the
first thing you might do is maybe try to
go back to something like this okay but
it doesn't lead you anywhere really okay
what you need to do to make why the
subject is think about what kind of
equation is this okay now i think
probably the easiest way to see it is to
multiply across like so
and then move this guy over with all the
rest of them actually maybe I'll put
them on the left-hand side this is what
I've got okay now I know that doesn't
look much better than we had before okay
but believe me it is you can deal with
this equation you can do this equation
in exactly the same way but you could
deal with an equation like this okay
because we all know what to do with this
right you say what is this thing what
would be your next line after this you
would say sine X and then you would
start doing the quadratic formula
because it's not a quadratic equation in
X anywhere it's a quadratic equation in
sine X ok now it's a little bit hard to
see because of this industry think here
really okay but either have to why is
really either power of Y squared that's
just indexed laws okay just like this is
what you're a little more used to seeing
this is a quadratic in either the way ok
now it's totally confusing cuz you like
what's that X hang around and therefore
ok well the exactly the same thing that
this negative 3 is doing he's going to
be a coefficient their problems okay so
just like over here my first instinct is
sine X and launch into the formula what
I'm going to do it here say either y and
then I'm going to launch into the
formula what do I get what's negative be
in this case it's just eggs that's the
coefficient or after okay plus or minus
and then you want you to this guy
that'll be B squared minus 4 a.c get
double negative caps off all over 2a
which is just too okay that's the hard
step that's the hard steps seeing that
seeing this and recognize that it's just
like this which you've done to death
okay this thing here X plus or minus the
square root of x plus 4 you also need to
be watchful for okay
because how am I look at this guy I've
got two solutions here do you expect two
solutions no and in fact not only do I
not expect it I don't want two solutions
because I rubbed it off two solutions is
not an inverse function it's an inverse
relation ok so I have to resolve this
somehow that the question is how how can
I get rid of one of them obviously one
of them is bad I have to reject one here
are the two options you've got this guy
and then you've got this guy okay now
one of them is burgers the question is
which one okay I think back to something
we looked at in periods ero today in the
two unit exam okay we actually have some
restrictions on these at least we're
supposed to they are implied in the
equations we've got here okay because
these are supposed to be equal to
allegedly either why I won't even why I
can't just be equal to anything you like
it's restrictive where is it restricted
it's positive isn't it whatever value of
y you stick in here that's real you're
going to get positive numbers okay so
therefore I should expect these guys to
be positive right this looks like it
presents no problems I can stick numbers
man ah but this guy's an issue why is he
issue yeah yeah this guy this guy here
the square root of x squared plus 4 will
always be bigger than X every time so
you're taking this a small number take
away big number this guy this guy's
negative it's not gonna work ok so
that's why I can reject that solution I
can say I only want this one as what
it's equal to either why that has to be
positive for all values of Y ok so
that's how I discount that solution and
that's a mark right there really ok ok i
am almost there what was the point i did
the first thing which is easy which is
switch variables the second thing i need
you to do is change the subject I'm so
close I want y equals what does your
both sides take logs
okay that is three marks worth of work
isn't it okay if I was marking this and
I did not but if I were on the places
where i would expect to see than three
marks are underway you where you would
put them I think I put my first one here
rearranging this and see I can put it
into the form of a quadratic in e to the
Y that's hard okay next step here
getting the quadratic getting getting
either YB the subject and then my last
step down here making it floored for
whatever okay this was really
interesting because they said solve this
they said hence they pointed big bold
letters and they even said do it saw it
as a quadratic which should have been
that other alarm bell to say oh right
there's a clue anyway so the question is
what how else do i solve it I lost ice
on this thing well this guy I recognize
this guy from the earlier parts that's f
of X ok so what I really want is for f
of X to be equal to 3 if I get that I'm
fine okay now stop think it said hence
so you have to take everything you just
sit over the last and the top minutes a
big how did that relate to this at all
well the bulk of that effort in this
question was spent on getting an inverse
okay this is actually not why this is
properly speaking because the terms they
gave it to us in what F and F inverse so
we spent all this time getting universe
what are inverses for right in verses
are for undoing the original function
that's what an inverse does right so if
i take F inverse of the whole one F
inverse of this ad F inverse of this
right
well this should collapse right that's
what an inverse is all about okay it's
just x and so this is going to be 3 plus
the square root of nine plus four is 13